okay well for people who are joining us
on the live stream this is a meeting
about design of our geometric scene
system for doing kind of Euclid style
geometry and other things so let's take
a look at what we've got here just the
stuff run by the way and what I have
here in the runs in the prototype build
okay um okay so I'm Roger have you seen
the stuff to this level or not we had
one previous meeting said I don't know
how much different it is from that that
was a while ago okay all right so let's
let's take a look can we see some basic
examples here just to get us started if
I click this will I get to the
documentation yes okay all right so
geometric scene is the way of
representing a symbolic piece of
geometry
yes okay this contains just to be clear
for the you know for the Roger team this
contains both things like circle which
are already supported by the rest of our
system circle through which is not angle
bisector what is an angle bisector is it
a is it a thing which has a size or is
it a what isn't it's a it's an infinite
line okay so it is so it's a way
essentially it's an alternative
representation of a line object in some
sense it's specified not by the points
that it goes through but by the points
that it is the bisector of the angle
between is that correct right and
luckily it bisects both the small angle
and the reflex angle because an infinite
full line right okay
okay so all the things that are here
there are certain things like circle
through which in principle for purposes
of geometric computation could be just
turned into pure circles is that correct
I mean for purposes of geometric theorem
proving circle through is a different
creature than circle but for purposes of
like working out you know a distance or
something using computational geometry
it could be turned into a circle is that
correct correct if you don't accept
parameters I mean if it all symbolic
parameters yeah if it auto evaluates the
it's not gonna water evaluate but it's
got to maintain its symbolic character
for the geometric theorem proving but
it's probably a smooth transition
between the two
obviously for three concrete points we
can find a circle for 14 concrete points
we might find the circle concrete points
doesn't circumscribe already do that
yeah for exactly three circle through
comes along comes with the assertion
that you know even if we have more than
three points they are canceling I see if
you give four points that are not on a
circle what does it do so if inside of
geometric scene if you specify these
points in there knocking cyclic then
there will be no scene that seems wrong
if you're trying to draw see yeah and
what's the what's good behavior outside
of geometric same is it this position
just remain unavailing and issue a
message this is one of the of the
discussion points like okay but so let's
just take a look okay so this is an
example down here and and and did you
say okay that you think this is runnable
right and so i can actually let me let
me just open this in the in the
prototype kernel
okay and now hopefully Ike
okay let's go back here all right
geometric scene opening in the prototype
kernel and now if I go down here and I
get something like this just so I
understand put this in here
okay so geometric scene of the points
ABC you know triangle ABC circle through
ABC and with Center Oh Oh is the
midpoint is that really a capital P for
midpoint mission that okay I think
that's a typo right you should if you
change the capital P toe lowercase P
it's a guy all these symbols are blue so
this makes me suspect can you do dollar
version I mean there was some issue
wasn't something latest bill there's one
from this morning that in it's and it's
on that one okay so I can't run this is
what you're telling me but if I could
run it it will produce this instance
here yes correct
differences obvious right although
although it is unclear to me exactly how
that so you should have a random seating
option renew okay good on that subject
okay so then these are the way the
geometric scene works is it will have as
its as its first argument instead of the
symbolic ABC oh it'll have actual values
given for that right correct
yes that's what fine geometric seen
instance does is it basically fills in
those specific values exactly correct
and also values for some
auxiliary points and variables that get
introduced internally I don't understand
that I mean so that there's some kind of
cash thing inside there but mean the the
the visible part of this is that it has
filled in instead of this geometric
scene that has wow that's weird that's
an in what the heck is that
oh that's uh I see if I made this a
standard form sell it still type well
why did you make this an input form sell
I don't come standard form it is that
image I see I see in the in the official
version okay all right but so this is
what it is internally and you're saying
that there's some cash that contains
additional geometric resolution so to
speak that we don't see here is that
right no there might be points that you
need are still explicitly mentioned and
how what are they called
they so currently they have a geometric
point head and there's some string
descriptors inside just for debugging
purposes
there's eternal world ultimately that
kind of you you ID'd points yes there's
a very eight points yes okay and at this
point sometimes there are there scalar
scalar quantities actually I'm not quite
sure why the radiant usually for a
circle that's a automatic radius if it's
not specified and I don't see one
specified here so I'm not sure why
that's not showing that all right okay
so now what is this how did that get
fine geometric conjectures inside it
here I don't know what this is doing so
fine geometric conjectures returns what
it returns a geometric scene but now the
third argument has a list of conjectures
added so okay so the third argument
you've got a lot of background noise
that by the way so the third argument of
geometric scene you're saying is a
so I don't understand what this is where
the fifth one sorry
the fifth one is to convince the third
argument one well okay there's some
conjectures about the scene but these
are not necessarily truths about the
scene they're merely conjectures yeah
they're conjectures based on based on
the concrete coordinates and scalar
quantities returned by the it's not just
a cache or is that something that the
user would actually care about at this
point yeah foodie expert II present yes
and somebody might extract them correct
they for them to show up they would have
to they would have to explicitly run the
find new metric conjecture so they were
to be expecting them I mean the outside
of the scene they are not very useful I
understand because they relate to the
local variables and seat okay what's the
dunes in geometric facts and geometric
conjectures fake Sofia moved okay okay
so then what does it return what does
fine geometric facts return does it also
just fill things into a geometric scene
or does it return something different
that's not good yet that's it's it
should be outside in the geometric scene
okay that's good that really doesn't
seem right to have one thing called find
your metric conjectures one thing find
geometric facts and they would turn
completely different structures find
geometric proof will return a proof
object which is going to be one of the
types of steps that will be there that's
a different let's keep this phone all of
this code okay okay now we get into the
meat yeah
okay so a bunch of these are things
which are like equal except they're not
equal well no because these are these
are these are you need you need very
limit properties right they eat one
thing correct right epi angular is the
assertion that this polygon has all
equal angles and all right I understand
although one could imagine a case where
one might want a second argument they're
all equal and they're all equal to 60
degrees or something perhaps I don't
know that perhaps a silly case ok so
these are these are Q like functions
except that they don't actually they're
not actually Q functions because they
don't force a resolution because they
could have something symbolic inside
them like they they stay there if they
can't come to a conclusion right but the
question is making them come to a
conclusion for X petit one might be a
lot of work for the geometry team but
what does geometry team have to do it
because because I thought the geometry
team works this the expedite things
because we are Berkeley working mostly
the symbolic ones but so the question is
okay look region convex would be a good
example so if I have some region
specified by some you know
discretization of a picture of a you
know a flat picture of an elephant or
something you know how do I determine in
our in our computational geometry system
how do I determine if that's convex
Roger I mean we have I don't know we
have a convex region to find I don't
hoots to find this but isn't defined yet
so let's just let's let's be very clear
let's just let's just play around and
just understand what we're talking about
okay so let's say I do this how do I
make that into a region region
discretize
Roger no you miss mish yeah okay well
actually what I want to do is some color
negate that okay so now I've got a mesh
now I want to find out if this is convex
how do I do that but there is no
released function yet okay so you can
use the definition but there will be a
lot of work okay but I mean it's that in
the works for yes okay fine okay all
right so that's so that's an example of
one that is non-trivial because fine you
know if you've got a list of points it's
pretty easy and I think you know that
the geometric scene team could implement
that for a list of points but for a
general case like yeah I mean never
gonna become X so it's always you could
just return it to constant false what do
you mean never gonna become X okay okay
I mean a polygon right yeah we already
have it right but it clearly doesn't
work for meshes and we won't expect it
to but that's something that's coming
from the computational geometry effort
and we implement it for polygons fine
but yeah whatever okay so something like
it needs to be very fast it needs to it
needs to be robust yeah fine but I mean
you know in terms of the code path there
you know what we're talking about that
the main issue here is we've got things
that in order to fill out our
computational our geometric proving
system we need certain primitives some
of those primitives will have been
reached by the computational geometry
team will be blindingly fast and will
work on anything but some won't have
been but I still needed in order to have
this geometric proving system actually
be sensible it is it's more about
relations in poverties okay fine but I
mean is that a fair summary or did I get
that wrong somehow well I mean the best
doing me these to all be primitives
right I mean I understand I understand I
mean the alternative would be geometric
property with a string right right and I
don't know the answer to that but if
they are in the path of what Rogers team
is gonna do anyway then we might as well
introduce them as primitives but have
them not yet work on more ornate kinds
of constructs you know if we think the
design is right but let's take a look at
what some of these are a lot of them
makes no sense
I mean equiangular you know so is a disk
equiangular
you would only work for polygons right
like we discussed last time I mean
during those meetings right does you
know we needed first to cook those and
you know those property or those
primitive based on the object somewhat
for polygons some are not that general
that's one point some are just working
for line for point does it what to make
them actually be a vegetable I judge I
did just statement like subset so me net
object I'm sorry what are you saying so
you're saying that they are intended to
be inert on a symbolic object right not
necessary because we you know we do
symbolic computation on the geometric
object so if you give you know a line
width you know you know symbolic you
know value ABC points we actually
compute on that written a statement
sorry what's an example of this or arc
length of line CD so you do mean
explicit coordinates you don't mean
symbolic points that well right okay
beautiful so sort of one of my concerns
about the relations on points is that
these are very very general names which
don't even sort of makes sense in
general right clockwise that's not
that's crazy that's not gonna make it
okay but I mean the question is do we
want an equiangular polygon predicate
basically or do we want to call it so
that would be equally angular polygon
which is probably the right name for it
do you agree do you disagree I I agree
and that's what we've been introducing
now we build polygon polyhedral sub
systems and if they only apply to that
they should have a name that gives you a
hint
what is it confusing that regular
polygon is a constructor and equiangular
polygon yes it's terribly confusing so
ugly wrong okay so might as well bring
that up here I have meant to introduce
and have that discussion later but the
problem is the Q function are sort of
useless for anything symbolic mm-hmm you
know and so we've been doing up until
now to not use a Q ending because it
can't be you know because there will be
Liars most of the time yep and but it
would be nice to have another ending for
things that are conditional you know so
I you know so if it's something that's
ultimate value is boolean I returned you
know one proposal is to have them end in
C so I introduced a convention that
doesn't have the restrictions of Q but
still gives you a hint I mean I've been
unhappy with Q as being obscure over the
last thirty years to have another um I
mean look another possibility would be
to end in test which is less obscure I'm
not I'm not necessarily claiming it's
perfect but instead prefixing is I'm not
sure horrified but I you know you know
there's many Horrors going around here
okay right so my can my objection to
test is I mean right if when we're using
it as an assertion then it seems that
yeah
I agree well okay but if the problem
we're trying to solve so so Roger what
do you think about an is and how many of
these do you have do you have a whole
boatload of them or do you have from
well they come in in all kinds of areas
not only geometry guess we you know we
have well I mean asymptotically equal is
an example of one that you've introduced
recently right right and that's okay I
mean that's that's not that's not
horrifying it's it's it but but there
are others well there's a whole new slew
of inequalities but like what in vector
less vector less equal what does that
mean it means vector ordering so
ordering them vector spaces okay
partial orderings okay but that's not
that's not hurting the QED business
either no function classification is it
non-negative function here are some
examples of things we've been thinking
about by jected function see convex
function see kind of like this evening
okay really don't like it I really don't
like it I think it's it's inconsistent
without other conventions okay so this
is a and I really like is by jected
function either I mean I think that's a
and I really like test so we don't have
a solution for this but let's imagine
that we had a small decoration that we
could give
um that would indicate that it is a
testing function or boolean valued
really yeah
I don't know offhand okay um but I
understand the point that there are
these things which are kind of a test
for whether it is a such and such but
now in the geometry case I mean so what
we imagine a tit butter or a statement
like when you say why they suspect
resolve and reduce it is not a test it
is a statement right right
and that's been a very nice you know
that's worked well for for you know
three decades or whatever and so the
difficulty now is that it is much less
obvious that when you say by jected
function that you don't just mean a
function that happens to be a by
ejection that you're now defining here
and that instead you are making an
assertion or your your representing
symbolically the statement that this is
a by directive function you know
initially at least it will not be used
in this assertion but it will it will
have to give conditional it has to be
give be able to give formulas you know
things that are not constant true or
false
right I understand I understand but I
mean so what you're saying is the
initial use will be as a test rather
than as an assertion
well test in a more you know know as
generating simpler conditions yeah I see
this is the constant right right so is
isn't really the right thing either is
it
I mean it's well what about autos or
Porsches but fully sped out condition
instead of see a little bit long but
it's pretty clear okay so what would it
be
by directive function condition
conditions
that there is actually by jected
condition might not be terrible in that
case the entry did by activity Quentin
yes that's pretty nice so then this
would become Equis angularity condition
it sounds beautiful it wunst yeah what I
mean no I like that by Jack tivity
condition sounds pretty nice to me
if what you want to return is what is
the condition for this function to be by
ejected if you think that most of the
time it won't be true or false but it'll
be some more complicated condition well
at least it needs to I don't I'm not
sure about most at a time it depends on
your prior assumption on the
distribution of problems yeah I
understand but it needs to be able to
deal with that case and Q cannot well I
mean look by jekt avati doesn't seem
completely crazy for that that seems to
journalist I think so too
why because it might not be a function
yeah there are all kinds of by H
activity but look I think your main
problem is by jected function by because
it could be like compiled front you know
it's the same parts of speech as
compiled function and so on that's where
that runs into trouble function by
activity runs into a lot less trouble
okay what about non-negative
well I mean the obvious thing to do
would be that
I mean it's a little weird because we've
got
negative as a well actually non negative
would be okay I mean in in other words
we could say function non negative
I'm not certain
these don't strike me is absolutely
horrifying but let's loop back here for
a minute to the equiangular polygon
business so first point is if we're
going to do that you know it will be
more polygon but by virtue of that
naming convention that we just talked
about it will be polygon equiangular
that wouldn't be bad in my I was just
going to say that I like that I do too
because it's also it's in spirit of you
know so we've done that for the region
functions if it applies to that full
level of generality mmm they typically
have region first fine all right so
that's a possibility that so let's look
at okay so let's let's go down some of
these so this will be polygon
equilateral and you know personally
these are concepts that are in around
since Euclid you know let's give them
frigging symbol names I mean I just
don't think I don't know what Roger do
you want to comment on that point I
think that there are many names
introduced through history that then
disappears but these are these ones are
they are fine they turn around for 2,000
years they're gonna stick around for
triangles yeah you know what in 2,000
years they've been applied to triangles
well this means it's a regular pentagon
right it's an equip and to gone with all
the sides equal doesn't it I mean yeah
no decent fine series are even useful
slightly useful in in actual geometry
okay fine all right I'll just think oh
yeah yeah okay yes I got it I got it I
gotta do something stupid
okay um all right let's keep going here
so so what enough this clockwise mean
okay that's probably one of the hardest
maybe maybe let's put this 104 later
well I mean why isn't that essentially
point points clockwise or something
yeah it'll most likely be applied to the
vertices of a polygon so despite it not
being technically true that polygons can
be oriented we might want to accept
input with head polygons fine but okay
that doesn't strike me as okay so
collinear then becomes points collinear
that's that is that wrong in any way no
I mean it seems it seems reasonable to
me
um okay so we've got similar kinds of
things here equal angles
horribly yeah we recently came up with
the potential replacement for four equal
angles no one seems to like that what
what is the replacement so we're going
to have what did we call it angled
partition so we're going to have a kind
of angles kind of straddle the boundary
between a measure you know angle measure
and you know the actual physical object
so it was going to be kind of a
constructor where we have the angle
partition a list of points followed by a
single point where the angle actually is
and there'd be an assertion that the
list of points would be in some sort of
counterclockwise
order this is way too complicated what
is this condition here I have an entire
section on this topic below
okay all right basically if we want to
try secta mango or something insect and
angle okay well maybe you know some of
these things so one question is whether
every single obscure thing like this
gets an actual symbol name or whether we
have a fall through somewhere that is
some kind of geometric property where
you can throw you know random things
into a string I don't know what's a good
idea there I would prefer not to have to
do that I would prefer to just decide
you know this is kind of what Euclid
used and what people have used since and
yes its twenty functions but let's just
put them all in but if it's two
unbelievable I mean you know at some
point we could say is it you know we
could have some it says is it an app
alone Ian packing or something and that
would be a silly thing for us to have
okay let me ask a different question so
do you and Jennifer find this they
example form a buffaio despites the
maiming points you stick in a polygon so
if this is generally allowed then that
might be a solution okay but but I've
got a different comment some of these
things are essentially mini you know
that there are such okay so you build an
assertion out of these primitives right
but these primitives you know any one of
these that there's certain number of
these primitives that are genuinely
primitives but then you can build all
kinds of other assertions out of
collections of those primitives and you
could build an arbitrarily complicated
assertion out of collections of these
primitives but it would not be named as
a primitive so my question is go ahead
there most of them I don't see anyone
here that is a primitive in the sense
that if you specified all the points
it depends on the input now but but most
of them specify sort of a feature right
so they constrained a set of possible
regions yes
space of relations so yes right we do
that but what I'm saying is there must
be a derived relation okay that is you
know those things are pairwise tangent
and they're parallel and whatever else
there's a derived relation and I'm
saying I don't know which of these are
you know can't be derived from each
other versus which of these are sort of
higher-level relations which could be
handled in a different way but I feel
like for the intended audience it is
pretty important that we are being able
to state the scene more or less as a
textbook if said I agree I agree but I'm
arguing for if I did no no I I
understand that I'm arguing let's
imagine that there's something like
pairwise tangent okay that is really
derived from two other properties and
it's this is true and that's true and
this is true for all that etc etcetera
etcetera
am I making sense yeah then my question
is you know we could imagine some
mechanism I don't know what it is yet
I mean clearly we could then define you
know pairwise tangent whatever it is of
you know VARs colon equals blah blah
blah it would evaluate I mean I'm but
this might try to put it in another
complexity class so pairwise tangent
does that take a point so it takes two
things or a list of things in a point
mutually tangent with pairwise tangents
if you have you know three or more
objects there'd be multiple points of
tangency potentially so okay but the
thing I'm trying to understand is
you could have an infinite number of
these kinds of you know it's mutually
tangent and this and it's that it's
whatever right have an infinite number
of relations which are practical
purposes say a hundred covers every
single German expert I you know if I
think about these things algebraically
is there's some theoretical reason to
think there's a certain collection of
relations about polygons the poly
polynomials or whatever and this is it
and there's no more or is it it's sort
of a unbounded because you know clearly
if we were going to give criteria about
polynomials for example there's an
infinite collection of possible you know
that the eleventh coefficient is greater
than two point seven times the 14th
coefficient you know there are all kinds
of conditions I could give like that and
I could name that the kind of a the you
know the balanced eleven fold condition
or something and I could give it some
explicit name but that would be kind of
silly is this making any sense I'm just
trying to understand which of these are
sort of fundamentally primitives and
which of them are somehow derived from
other primitives and then I'm trying to
understand how would we name the things
which are essentially the derived
relations but but this will depend on
your axiom system and makes it not zero
to a normal user but Michael look look
if you say a B and C are congruent and
such and such is true right I'm writing
that out explicitly I could rename that
that conjunction to be some other
condition called foo right yes but this
misses the point the point is there are
hundred thousand textbooks in geometry
out and we try to be able to represent
what they say in their language we don't
try to implement the theoretically
possible world but all right fine fine I
understand I'm still making the point
there might be some obscure geometry
textbook out there that uses a relation
that we are not
going to build in as a primitive okay
okay so then what I'm asking for is
under those circumstances we have a
subsidiary definition I don't think that
way of doing it is quite right but we
have some kind of subsidiary definition
maybe it's part of the geometric scene
structure maybe it's in the first
argument of the geometric scene I don't
know some subsidiary condition right
that represents this derived relation
I'm a making sense but why wouldn't you
not just define a function that then how
do you evaluate it expands to the full
set of is fine that's fine that's what
I'm saying here you might not want that
because you might want to have the thing
be able to be sitting there in the
expression that you put in as a piece of
symbolic stuff that hasn't yet
evaluation I mean it's almost like you
know the N value of something you know
if I have PI squared plus Catalan or
something well if I if I if I define my
own constant plus the Foo constant okay
then if I say n of this right I'm still
gonna get foo but I could define the N
value for foo which will not evaluate
symbolically but will evaluate if I hit
it with N and so I think this is going
far too far this mean that we need a
whole framework to for the user to add
new definition so that then the seen
code understands this definition this is
evaluating it I understand I I think it
could be done in the in the kind of
precursor argument of the you know the
set up argument of geometric scene but
let's not go that doesn't matter I mean
look it's clear that a bunch of these
are harmless
I'm less you know the ones where I don't
even know what it means
I'm having where you have to say eight
sentences to say what it is I'm a little
less convinced by you know collinear
yeah I understand what it is and it's a
pretty simple description and it makes
sense to have that as a primitive I just
I don't know where you draw the line you
know how many geometry books does it
take before you decide a function needs
to be in there versus it's stranded
sorry we're not gonna support it am i
making sense can you answer that
question I mean you know
there are 200 phrases that are commonly
used okay we're not are we seriously
imagine we're gonna help no baby sing
kinda become mostly away this what is
he'll before we go on it's a slightly
technical point but I wanted to talk
about parallel and perpendicular are we
thinking we're going to name you
something else
or are we really thinking we might stick
with parallel perpendicular because I
cannot imagine we want to have the word
parallel in that no right yeah so
perpendicular is so let me just provide
context perpendicular is an existing
symbol that you know formats as a little
perpendicular thing and yeah and then
the thing that should be called parallel
by analogy with perpendicular is
actually called double vertical bar oh
God
so if you right which is why I'm just
saying maybe we should yeah so if you do
double vertical bar of a B and that is
the unicode character that is the
unicode character for parallel it
doesn't look particularly yeah you'd
need to like do two boxes and full form
of the two boxes of percent 14 and I'm
not sure if he gave it an actual long
name but of course the long name is
double vertical right but if you look up
the code point that this corresponds to
this is the code point and the Unicode
tables which is reserved for parallel
for the parallel symbol so I'm just
thinking we should dear clear
pre-existent that come go ahead yeah so
I'm just saying I think we should stick
clear up using perpendicular and
parallel by themselves because of let's
put that on the I understand your point
I generally agree with the conclusion
though not necessarily for
reasons you're stating it would be it
would be cool to be able to use this
perpendicular symbol to represent that
wouldn't it or is it not do we not care
I mean like co-linear is there a
notation for that okay the line example
say one often speaks about in 3d about
parallel planes we would have probably
plane poly or light I know I'm not
convinced that line parallel is the is
the right term
you know geometric geometrically
parallel I don't know we you know once
we've got agreement about the general
form of names here we can go and try and
deal with detailed ones okay you know I
could imagine we could use geometrically
as a prefix to some of these things
I mean I could even imagine that this
one could be geometrically clockwise
maybe in general we should go to the
next section to see what is the
alternative because its own issues the
moment you leave TV absolutely haven't a
clue what it means um okay so this is
geometric property is is the thing wave
one would have those be represented by
strings but right which I'm not a
particularly fan of that's kind of nice
it wonders that bootable things can be
done at once right so there are certain
seams where it's implicitly assumed that
say all polygons are oriented the same
way so it's nice that you can just in
one command so you need to find the
polygons and you say okay well what
could have both things one could have a
wrapper function here which gosh that's
getting kind of weird which is a
multiple assertion right so so I mean
what would that look like in in other
cases if one says blah is greater than
blah I mean what that it that's an and
basically but but the problem is you
have to repeat the thing you say a is
greater than B and a is greater than C
right or in a single predicate you would
say some predicate P of a and P of B no
I'm sorry and Q of a right and the point
is there's no what does all true do does
it relate to this
people list right yeah it just returns
and right it's an ad ads no it's fine
fine but this construct of taking you
know multiple conditions so this is
basically I mean I'm writing it out in a
silly form but I mean like all
conditions
you know PQ coma a it's basically what
that is is something though there's not
the right name but one could have a
general thing which is I mean ultimately
what what is this operation so given
you've got got a reducer you've got you
know a it's kind of a weird operation
right that that takes a it's an
operation that would take PQR takes an a
and takes a reducer right what is that
well in any case let's say you know
that's essentially a general multiple
conditions thing which one could imagine
using in the way of what if one has
explicit functions for everything that
makes sense yeah so this is the
geometric property way of doing all of
this stuff okay what is this what is
that for the things that have to
generate different arguments like via I
think that's horrifying
right then geometric property has to
somehow plug the other argument in yeah
right
that's pretty grotesque right it really
only came up with tendencies and
currencies but yeah it's not a great
solution um okay
oh boy we've got quite a lot of stuff to
go over here and we are running out of
time right now um okay look I mean this
is this is at least another two hours
worth of stuff um what on earth is this
well that's not too bad Roger do you
want to comment on this
suppressing messages I don't see a
problem with particularly but what's we
do suppress the message so for sure
those dozen okay
now issue like regular polygons which
doesn't fit the current specification so
that's kind of too far that's I'm sorry
what do you sound then what are those
things down there I don't understand
what regular polygons let that's a
representation of a regular polygon
whose symbolic corners are ABCD right
this is a square with vertices ABC in
any orientation at any position okay
well and and so from the point of view
of the rest of the system I mean are you
imagining I mean I think has some
evaluation semantics but rectangle maps
directly to a rectangle box so I'm
concerned about my point that there is
the radius this thing the regular
polygon take out theta there is some
confusion during the passing no I mean
that makes sense but that's fine but
it's do we need a separate constructors
but we need to final till all that in
that same constructor I don't think we
try to put it in the same constructor I
mean okay so this there's some
complexity here because this is this is
essentially an assertion that the points
ABCD lie on a regular polygon you're
different from the constructor yes and
then likewise for for the line stuff
above you know if you have more than two
points yeah I mean this is really much
more of a you know regular polygon
condition or something regular polygon
corners it's more specific or vertices
oh did you mean when you said ABCD are a
but it's specifically four corners well
if it's a square yes give me anything by
anything well I mean if you have you
every mercy is for mornings five right
but but if you have five vertices then
to Pentagon yes right okay so this is
really an assertion about a set of
points that they form a regular polygon
yes
but inside geometric scene it also works
as a constructor so you can ask for the
area that you know okay okay this is
kind of complicated guys I mean as
you've realized and we only schedule an
hour for this which is obviously not
adequate so let's try to pick this up
again early next week and I think it's
going to be a two-hour extravaganza um
Roger do you want to make any other
comments before we you know I think we
just have to plan on scheduling this and
try and go through it and there gonna be
a bunch additional things angry
I think that's minimum required right I
mean I'm the things that are easy to do
and there are things that are you know
very
yeah I won't prejudge it I think we just
need to work through it yeah I think
there are a lot of these I mean there's
a separate issue which is what the
traditional form of something which is a
decorated name ends up being because
essentially we've got a symbolic
representation for a you know some
expression I don't know whether you have
one you have one in some of these cases
here right so the question is what's the
traditional form of this because the
traditional form could be a nice
triangle picture ABC I don't know what
you know how you write out circle
through and then maybe cases where it is
somewhat verbose if you type the thing
out but many people will not do that
they'll either see something closer to
traditional form or they will be
entering you know natural language stuff
to get it so that the you know so when
we're trying to protect from verbosity
at the you know internal level that made
me misguided okay it's the end of what I
had to say all right thanks everybody
let's pick this up again early next week
okay okay see you guys bye